so Maisie we're here on the set of up on
the roof tell me what the films about
it's about homeless children and it's
kind of a really raw story about boy
called Michael who kind of gets himself
into a bit of trouble and a Gokul Trish
she doesn't really help the situation
she's very free and trying to convince
Michael that there's more to life than
just staying up on this rooftop and you
know he's got so much more to explore
into to live for and I kind of think
she's give him a kick in the right
direction but maybe you know gets him
into a bit of trouble in the way so yeah
it's exciting what kind of character is
she well I think um she likes a male
attention a lot I think and um that's
another kind of issue you know she she
messes around with people a little bit
but I think is because maybe she's never
had a father figure or you know I think
she's there's a lot to history that you
never really get to hear about and are
the sort of questions that you have at
the at at the end
um at the end of the script I have a lot
of questions I speaking to nor the
director and just you know I think it's
um yeah there's a lot more to the story
than you first you first see and enter
the characters as well and I think
that's what you know that's why I liked
it at least so how do you get into a
character like that when there's so much
more to kind of know about them cuz it's
a short film isn't it yeah I think with
the costume and the hair and the makeup
and things it's really I mean they're
all my own clothes but I never usually
wear the weather like this or and I
think you know being here and being up
on the roof in the middle of London and
um you know it's it's really kind of
real and I feel like I'm actually here
and and yeah it's a lot of improvising
as well which is nice to kind of just
make it feel more natural and and yeah
really really get into it and um yeah
it's just different to what I've done
before I think and I'm you know looking
forward to more characters that are my
age and I think that's different I'm
usually depicted as a younger person or
like a tomboy or something and this time
she's like you know a real teenager and
I think it's just kind of different and
yeah people get to see a new side to me
as well tell me about working with your
co-stars on the film as well yeah it's
really exciting
um Michael is fantastic you plays
character Marcus and there's a few other
lads here today that I haven't actually
worked with yet we'll be doing those
things later but yeah all fantastic
young actors and it's yeah it's great to
do things like that with people your own
age as well to see you know you can be
working with them again in the future
and this is your sort of generation of
actors growing up and yeah it's really
exciting
I'm very different of course for what we
know you for best I a stalk on Game of
Thrones both in terms of the age you're
playing and of course as the type of the
age of the actors you're working with as
well how does it compare then I think
it's kind of different you know like
this is a lot smaller scale but somehow
no it's it's um a lot more intimate
maybe and there's a lot more time to
just talk to the director and you know
get your head around what's going on and
and I think with Game of Thrones
sometimes a little bit go go go and it's
nice to have you know an idea of what's
going on every second of the day well
this is just completely different and um
you know I still really love it and it
to me really it's just about the story I
think and um the character and that
doesn't really matter if it's just a
short film or if it's you know Game of
Thrones a hugely successful TV series I
think it kind of just if if I like the
character and I like the script and you
know it's just the experience really I
find so this is you know up there
definitely with my favorite things that
I've done
what made it stand out for you I think
the rawness of the story really like
there's so many questions as I said
earlier I had at the end and you know
it's really kind of hits hard you know
what life is like and then but just
giving you like a small snippet it's not
like a big trolling on story about you
know it kind of just gives you a little
glimpse into what life is like for these
kids and how you know tricky they find
it and and then you come back out of it
again and you're left like oh but you
know what happens and what happened to
her and him and and yeah I just I was
you know flipping the page it's I was
with my friends and mum was like all you
need to need to read the script um my
agent really really liked it oh okay and
I was all my friends around and they're
like amazed you stop reading but going
on your emails I was like but mom I
can't start reading this so yeah I just
you know it's different to how I've
reacted to other scripts now of course
she's lived in a different world to IIST
but I stock also has her many problems
isn't she right from beginning and Game
of Thrones it had quite a journey in
season 3 haven't you how have you found
and what stood out for you oh I think
this year there was um I mean a lot
happened to Aria in season 2 and in
season 1 but I think this year really
picked up again re is meeting lots of
new characters and although I had a
fantastic year in season 2 she just
stayed in her and hope she got captured
staying Harrenhal left Harrenhal this
year she's been on the run she's got
taken by the Brotherhood we've now seen
and leave the Brotherhood I think it's
just you know there's a lot more a lot
of faster pace and it was great working
with so many different actors and I
think that's what I like about areas
every season is different you know you
never really know what's happening I
know this is books you can go by but
still those little changes here and
there and I really really enjoyed season
3 it was my favorite so far to film I
had a great time with all the other
actors and yeah it was just I feel like
I'm growing up now and this kind of like
getting more used to it and come onto
set and know everybody and the directors
and things and it just you know it
really felt like you know something I
could see myself in the future doing
this sort of thing it was the first time
that's kind of happened really I usually
just sort of think oh I'm gonna go away
and do this filming thing now and then
I'll go back to school you know but it
was really felt like I was part of it
which is nice so nice to hear when would
you like to see our going in future
because I guess there's so many options
for her aren't there yeah I think more
there's this I'm not gonna give any
spoilers for the book um but yeah I
thought I've always seen Arya is kind of
being on her own in the end like I mean
be grateful to get back to a family and
acknowledge them and like yeah you know
mom I'm safe you know but I think I
don't know she's one of the only
characters that could really do it alone
you know a lot a lot of characters need
their army or you know their dragons or
you know Joffrey isn't really anything
about Cersei and it's kind of everybody
needs their other people and Arya is
possibly you know fine on her own if not
stronger I think she could yeah kick ass
on her own so um that's kind of a good
quality to have seeing as everybody else
is usually you know against you and you
can't really trust anyone so um yeah I
think she'll do well on their own
the end and actually mention kicking out
so she's a real kick-ass character since
she and it kind of got me thinking
another really kick-ass character is hit
girl in the movie kick-ass what do you
think it'd be like if those two teamed
up I think that would be amazing you
know like well I think I was watching um
it was just bringing out number two
right and I was watching all the
trailers and it's just all the combat
work that Chloe Moretz does and I think
I met her stunt double as well and I
just you know it's really cool but it's
kind of different because it's
modern-day and stuff but I think they're
kind of the same character but present
day and medieval time but yeah it's it's
great all these strong female characters
that are coming out at the moment and um
it's very different you know these young
girls kind of you know fighting and it's
it's different to what we've seen before
and I'm kind of like the way it's going
and I get a lot of sort of fierce young
girls coming up in other scripts and
things it's definitely something that I
am you know I want to be a part of you
know this new thing that's coming up now
you mentioned stunts and fighting and
stuff at that maybe think of all your
sword fighting skills in Game of Thrones
of course how did it how is it training
to do that did your dance background
help with the choreography for that yeah
definitely I we kind of just learn a
routine and then you put it together
with a stunt guy so if you hit them it's
okay because they've got their pads on
things and then you go on with the other
actor and I'm so holy you know sort out
any issues that you have with each other
or any bits that you find difficult and
then you go ahead and film it but yeah I
think when I first started I'd never
done sword fighting before and Arya in
the books is left-handed and I'm
actually right-handed so I decided to
try it left-handed which was a bit of a
silly decision I realise now by the time
I was like yeah this is gonna be great
and I'm like why did you do that but um
I stuck to it now and it's fine you know
it just would have been easier like if
I'm really struggling with a move I'm
like put it in my right hand and do it
with using oh my gosh you know this
could be so much quicker but it's a
challenge and I like that and um you
know you're not every day that you can
still fight with your other hand
um in the future if I get any other
left-handed characters come up I can I
can give a go so yeah it's it's
definitely helped me and not hindered me
but it would be easier some days and you
believe you were doing some fencing as
well and a background to help yourself
yeah I did like a beginners course so
now I can go to any fencing lessons and
they'll take me in because I've done my
book my beginners bit but yeah it was
kind of different cuz the guy that I was
working with he kind of thought I was
mad he was like why don't left hand
again I was like well I'm in this show
and it's a long story but yeah he
thought I was a bit crazy but yeah it
was good fun and just nice to kind of
build up the strength and stuff as so
many characters who've had crossed your
path in the show haven't we we mentioned
about sword fighting and Syrio Forel
springs to mind would you like to see
him come back and what about meeting
Jack and her gar again would you like to
meet him yeah definitely I think I've
arias met some fantastic other
characters that she's really worked well
with and then unfortunately they all get
taken away from her and we never really
know what happened what happens to them
so you know we don't know that Syria's
Syria is dead so you know that he could
come back I guess I mean I said this in
an interview a while ago and everyone on
the internet was a comic Lord he's
coming back and was like guys that was
just my opinion I don't really know that
but yeah it would be really great to
work with all these other actors again
that's that's one of the things you know
like every year you get to meet new
people but then you got to leave your
friends behind and so yeah it's kind of
sad sometimes and the Hound her feelings
seems to be changing towards him don't
they and Joe Dempsey's Kendra's well
he's gone too yeah I know I think with
Ari in the Hound she kind of hates him
but at the same time he's really safe
with this guy because he's got all the
things that she needs like the respect
no one's gonna mess with the Hound so
she stole my own you know that's a good
place to be you know and then yeah
Gendry as well it kind of seems that
anyone that are at trusts gets a gets
taken away and um she's really trying
like with the the yeren relationship
she's kind of hooked up to his father
then he got taken away and she really
started to build up these barriers and
then he always thought you know she's
gonna look after hop buying injury and
then they leave and now she's really
kind of you know shutting everyone else
off
than its it's kind of scary I think for
someone so young to be saying some of
the things that she is and be reacting
to situations oh he is so we were
talking about the Hound now I wonder if
I had her three choices again for her
hit list you think she's picked the same
people or who did actually pick this is
a thing at the beginning of season 3
Gendry was giving her a hard time about
the people that she chose but I think at
the time he kind of didn't really um I
didn't really believe this guy could do
it so she was like okay the tickler you
know and this guy Liz you know not
really a great person and could do
without him so yeah and she wears oh you
know this is this is kind of cool and
then this is a memory launch afterwards
and that's because she really needs to
save her ass I think and she was kind of
in trouble so yeah but I think you know
at that time it was just the first one
was just like Oh a tester and then she
got herself into trouble so she had to
kind of kill those people quickly and
let's just get parent halt which is
quite clever I think but yeah I think
you know if she hadn't got herself into
that mess she would have chosen Joffrey
and Cersei and Ilyn Payne I don't know
in what order she would choose
definitely Ilyn Payne I think because he
seems like a bit of a psychopath and
Joffrey and Cersei oh I don't know I
guess if you took one of them away it'd
be kind of different for the other I'm
not sure I think Jeff I think I think
seriously without Joffrey that that
would be okay so if if we kill Joffrey
that'd be good
and we're talking about Harrenhal right
so that makes me think obviously of
Tywin Lannister you were his cup Bearer
how fun was it tricking Tywin yeah I
think it was great I really loved the
scenes when I first read them and and
then I was a little like oh god I'm
gonna be working with Charles dance you
know and I think that I think you know I
would just think he's a nobody and you
know there's something a little bit
different about her but I don't think he
really suspects that she's Robb Stark's
younger sister um because you know she
would have been a lot more trouble then
yeah I think she's just kind of cruising
under the radar and then Littlefinger
comes along and that kind of you know
she gets a bit yeah give me a bit aware
that you know she was kind of confident
in Harrenhal one bit like ah you know I
can I can deal with this and then kind
of spun it on this head a bit so then
she was a bit like oh god you know don't
get too comfortable there's still people
out there that kind of want to get you
so yeah it was kind of a different a
different thing that I was kind of come
across really and she's usually just
trying to convince people that she's
boring and now she's actually got
convince people that she's not herself
you know and it's um yeah it was very
different
to sort of have that other aspect to it
I think and um I got on really really
well with child dance and yeah the
scenes were fantastically written and um
just nice to be a part of that really
yeah they were brilliant scene so I know
they're on the book but they're superb
scene I'm glad they were in the TV show
we actually spoke to Charles Dancy the
day and he's singing your praises very
very highly and rightly too but we asked
him whether he thought giving enough
time that Tywin would have realized that
she was aiya Stark and he said yes he
would have done definitely what do you
think I think he's kind of wise and
eventually he would have worked out but
I think Arya was sort of quietly
confident that she would be gone by then
and um she didn't plan on staying after
the rest of her life so yeah I think she
kind of played her cards right then
maybe he he would have um just blow okay
you know you're doing all right you can
go what something I'm sure but um yeah I
think he possibly would have recognized
a given more time so it's good job girls
there when she did was he could be dead
right now so we didn't want to say no
definitely not never yeah what was it
like you said what it's like working
with Charles Dunn so what did you learn
from working with people like Charles
and Sean Bean as well Michelle Furley it
sounds weird it's kind of like the
ability to just incorporate props
it's just sounds I'm wrong but it does
make a complete difference like how
natural is and especially with the
language on Game of Thrones it's not you
don't feel like you'd naturally say that
and you know saying father and mother
and it's like I'm just like that's my
mum my dad you know perhaps so it's kind
of you know the language the stuff makes
it feel a lot less natural anyway
to incorporate your props and just be
able to relax on camera then makes it
feel a lot more believable I think and
especially in this world which is kind
of like a fantasy world so you don't you
know there's not much realism I guess so
it's you know that that is kind of an
element that I've learned from a lot of
actors to kind of make it look more
natural and feel more natural and yeah
that's important I think I want to ask
you about Melisandre because she said
that she sees darkness in you didn't she
what do you think about that um I think
that's kind of a bit of a wake-up call
to Arya and um she's already heard these
people like um Val Asim Bajwa modulus
and Valar dohaeris and I think she
realizes all there's more to this world
than I originally thought
and um and now Madison is coming out
with these things and she kind of was
just like Oh everything she says rubbish
and tries not to believe it but then you
know when she's really saying something
to you and saying you know I shall shut
forever it's kind of like oh you know
and um it could just be all rubbish but
still it does make you think and um yeah
it was an intense scene as well I can
grease grab my chin and like I couldn't
see and if the camera or anything were
just like looking into each other's eyes
and I was like oh it's kind of gave me
chills a little bit and it was um yeah
it's kind of scary and she died didn't
blink as well and that was kind of odd
like I was like where you gonna blink
and then sometimes I was there and I was
like when's she gonna blink I get back
into the Zeke magazine yeah but it was
um I remember reading it and being a
black Volvo you know this is a this is a
new thing to Aria and yeah it's kind of
chilling I think now who would you like
to see ultimately on that iron throne I
changed my opinion all the time and
there's so many people have asked me
this question and then you know they
expect one answer because I've said it
before and then I say something else and
they're like oh you didn't show up for
I'm like oh I don't really know um I
don't have a clue every guy I don't have
to make the decision in the end cuz she
said oh I'd really don't know who would
pick um there's so many fantastic
characters but then I know that George
you know if it's someone who you think
will get to the Iron Throne probably
won't be so yeah I don't know if someone
who deserves it I think
so yeah but I'm not sure I sometimes say
Daenerys I think she's kind of got the
right intentions and she's always been
trying to get to the throne and just
because they were there first really
it's not for anything else I think some
people are trying to get to get to the
throne but for revenge or you know just
to see the look on someone else's face
you know not really for themselves so I
think yeah she's kind of got the right
intentions he's interesting who spoke to
Alfie Allen recently as well and he said
he'd like to see aya on the throne I
think that's kind of cool um I need to
be a pretty good ruler but he's just
trying to get home really so it's not
really I guess that would be cool um I
think Aria would be quite a good hand
but to the right king so you know but
yeah I think she'd she'd do well in that
area and I know what you mean about not
changing your mind but he won on the
throne because we kind of changed our
mind about how we feel about different
characters of the seasons move on don't
worry yeah I mean Jamie Lannister for
one is completely shocked you know and I
knew that was kind of knew that was
coming in the inscript view too because
mum said well if you wait till season
today she'd read the books quit just
using through you really could see
another side to Jamie I was like all
right so I sort of knew that there was
something different coming this season
and we were in the read-through and um
and he's got a long bit of dialogue and
I remember thickening of the page
missing I was like okay I'm not QG I
sort of follow along as I'm just gonna
watch you know and listen then and
they're just you know you see a
completely new side these character that
you've always hated and never really
given an opportunity you never really
given a chance
yeah and I've actually kind of you know
pleasing your heartstrings a little bit
and um yeah it changes up a bit and no
one's really comfortable with always
changes and there's a new character
involved or you know this one's now body
and a goodie or yeah it kind of it it
keeps it interesting it keeps it really
interesting doesn't it and he's been
interact with a great female character
as well this season hasn't he Brienne of
Tarth yeah and Gwen Christie also had to
cut her hair as did you for the for the
show how was it when you had to cut your
hair so I believe that Gwen cried yeah
well I I get on really well with gran we
have a lot in common we're both women on
the show who don't really get to look
glamorous and we both had to cut our
hair and we work with swords and
and I think yeah I had a lot to talk to
her about when I first met her and we
both had a long hair we're like all I'm
getting mine cut in two weeks and
grandma said getting mine cut like
tomorrow and we're like all but I'd
already had short hair and in the past
so I knew it suited me and I my hair
wasn't really that long and I was kind
of just like yeah but I know Gwen's
struggle with it a little bit but she
looks fantastic and I'm kind of glad she
had it cut because it you know wigs are
really uncomfortable I had to wear one
for series one so I yeah I know that you
were kind of regret if he didn't cut her
hair so yeah and he looks fantastic so
yeah and it's it's something that we
have in common because you know it's
kind of odd when you're on Game of
Thrones there's a lot of sex and nudity
and stuff and being one of the female
characters there's more sort of a
masculine character I think and um I
think that's you know different and
everyone always thinks Game of Thrones
like oh well that's one with all the
sexy like yeah well not my character I'm
kind of you know this is you know one of
the biggest pom boys I've ever played so
yeah uh-huh
we we both have that in common which the
other characters you'd particular like
on the show if you weren't arya for
example who else would you like to be um
well I think there's so many great
characters it'd be cool to be a hated
character so Cersei would be quite a
cool character but I kind of like her as
well as it's strange
she's a complex character and then
Daenerys got a dragon so it'd be cool to
do some CGI and stuff because I did work
with the dogs but you know I did that
was so lost but I walls are soulless
yeah yeah so we call to work with them
like dragon warned up we were dragons
but you know to do that side of it but I
think Ygritte is really cool and she
comes out with it and is not afraid to
make people feel really uncomfortable
and um I think that's kind of funny she
talks a lot of sense
- so yeah there's not there's lots of
and they're all female characters I pick
as well she's very outspoken as well in
a way like iris he says he says what's
on your mind isn't she I know her line
you know nothing Jon Snow yeah yeah
exactly it's just a memorable and I
think she's um it's kind of
added a new side to that kind of
storyline now and it's a complication
maybe as Jon Snow's half-sister do you
agree that he knows nothing about some
things but yeah there's he knows things
yeah exactly
so half and half then yeah I think I
think maybe he knows more than she gives
him credit for but hey he's a woman
then tell me a little bit about working
with your co-stars as you said you work
with so many people have I knew yeah
I've been really lucky in that ari has
been is very well-traveled and I'm I get
to work with some fantastic other actors
and them it's just you know it's the
first job the first acting thing I ever
got and um I've been extremely lucky in
that I've you know learnt so much and
met so many people and you know she's
making an impression and and different
things have come out of it as well and
and like if I go to audition or
something they'll say oh well I just
have this feel my like oh well so once I
was on that and I know him from this and
and just gives like you connections and
things which is really important I think
in this industry and it's you know
really helped with all of that and um
yeah I'm I'm so grateful for such a
fantastic role in such a fantastic
series and it's been a real kind of
booster for my future really and we
would love you in it as well everyone
does you had a massively brilliant
reaction and fans and and absolutely
understandable - and who would you like
to work with you maybe haven't worked
with so far on the show um oh I don't
know I think um I kind of work with a
lot I mean if we call to do some scenes
in King's Landing like with Cersei and
Sansa and that kind of thing but I
didn't really know how that would work
character wise because she probably just
end up killing Cersei I don't know but
um you know it'd be cool to work with
Lena we have done a scene together but
you know have been that'd be cool she's
a fantastic actress and yes a shame that
I don't get to see her more
but yeah it would be cool to see my
family again and do some scenes with
like Michelle because we never really
had a one-on-one scene or anything it
would certainly have a big group scenes
that we had together so and just to see
like how people are on set really cuz
you know you meet them in downtime and
stuff but how they work and you know to
watch them acting instead of just on on
screen that'll be interesting so I have
to wait and see what happens it's always
keeps us excited doesn't it game I
suppose he's never quite know what's
gonna happen
yeah well it's been your most memorable
day of shooting so far um oh and series
three we had a big big fight scene with
a flaming sword and that took that took
three days to two and a half days and it
was great we had a lot of fun but it was
really hard as well there was a big
roaring fire going and I'm the week
before we'd been exterior the whole week
and it'd been raining in we're like how
it's getting to the paint hole gone to
the paint Horner's absolutely boiling
and we were like you know I'd much
rather be outside it was it was so hot
and they had to fight as well and they
had all that big armor on as well and it
kind of it just you know but we did have
a lot of fun but it was just really
trying day and very memorable and just
really impressive as well as kind of
like a fight scene that I'm not actually
fighting I was just sort of watching
which was cool and um yeah it was great
and it looks fantastic too and I just
remember being like and it's so hot as
well like the sword comes past you it's
like you know it would be so difficult
to fight with a flaming sword I think
but it was actually flaming as well
which is cool that they didn't CG that
it was it was genuine not genuinely on
fire so that was cool to kind of
actually see that that's incredible
definitely with any other moments that
you think a while you know if fans knew
the behind the scenes of Game of Thrones
what would they find surprising do you
think the beheading I think for a lot of
it um it was just guy really slowly
raising a sword and then lowering a
sword and then going cut and that was
kind of it for a lot of it then they
came closer and did I told you know how
they did it it was kind of fake head not
fake head Shan and fake body head blood
done
you see yeah it's kind of strange and I
think people it wasn't like his I was
kind of like because this is gonna be
amazing and then and then it was just
like Oh put the fake kid head in now
okay we'll take that out and we'll put
blood here and okay we're done I was
like oh okay I thought someone was gonna
actually get the head cut off or
something pretty cool you know so we're
gonna have like blood
wait was just yeah I think people be
like oh that was you know that was not
why I expected at all
I know what do you do when you kind of
cuz you have a lot of emotional scenes
as I you don't you can go to some quite
dark places how do you chill out how do
you shake all that off at the end of a
shoot um sometimes if it's a really an
emotional scene it's kind of hard to get
back sometimes and they call cut and
you're a bit like because you've just
really made yourself upset and I'm I
think just to chill out really a go back
to the hotel and either have room
service you can just sit in your bed
with your pajamas on or in between takes
and stuff I just make jokes with the
other casts and people come out and
cheer you up and you know usually when
it's really intense so just say
something and everyone will laugh in a
block okay you know bring it back up
again because everyone's kind of silent
and so it was a bit sad okay someone
brings it back up again which is nice so
yeah and sometimes it's hard to go from
like a really upbeat scene to a really
sad scene because you're still like and
then they're like okay right we're gonna
go on to this and you're like I'm not
quite there yet and not quite ready and
so yeah it's kind of a bit up and down
on set but I really enjoy it is it's
kind of different to anything else I've
ever done what obviously but um yeah
it's it's a mad world really you
mentioned Jack Thorne so he's the
biggest prankster he's the biggest Joker
on sense Ben hawky he constantly
imitates other people when it's not just
their accent it's like a complete
impression of someone and their
mannerisms and everything and he's like
see that guy over there and then just
starts doing it and I'm like how do you
even do that it's mad and does
impressions of people and you know
before we rolled as someone who you know
everyone saying quiet please no no and
there's like a little repetition of
things that people call out and Ben's
just there in the corner saying the same
things and why
Ben stop it we're supposed to be going
I'm supposed to be angry with you and
you're making me laugh and that scene in
Episode one where we're both walking
through the woods all three of us are
walking through the woods it was just
chuckling when it's on a wide shot he's
just you know constantly making jokes
and things and Joe also kind of you know
eggs Amman witches yeah he's really hard
they're like an action and I'm like oh
my god I got to stop laughing and take
this seriously and I'm like pull it's
get amazing but yeah it is great fun now
you mentioned I was he been hook he
plays hot pie what was his wolf bread
like um if you dry they made loads of
doubles of it that was like 60 wolf
bread things on this table just like and
they had a couple of different editions
of it so you know and they wanted to
pick the one look the most ridiculous
and so that one's hilarious especially
because she's like oh yeah that's the
tail and it was like massive this big
clump on the end of the bread I was like
yeah that was perfect
um but yeah it was kind of they've got
to make it look like you've got to make
it look good even if it doesn't taste
great because you know people aren't
gonna taste it from from there so for at
home so they got make it look good and
then sometimes it's like uh hum yeah
yeah we didn't have taste division for
that yeah uh-huh
definitely how many times did you have
to do that um I think only about four or
five times um yeah and the beginning you
know I always get excited when I was at
eating scene because I really love food
I'm like have it the first time I'm like
yeah it was really overrated let me not
I'm not crazy about this wolf bread so
now maybe what's it meant to you to be
part of Game of Thrones I think when it
all started I didn't expected to get as
big as it has and you know I now really
feel a part of it and I was there since
the pilot episode that we filmed and you
know it's it's slowly got bigger and
bigger and bigger I've always wanted to
perform and I finally got my foot in the
door and I'm excited to see what the
future holds
that sounds really cheesy but I am more
excited for you and we're so glad you
got the foot in the door I'm sure it'll
be wide wide open in
what would you like to say to the fans
out there who watchin it in to you mazey
um thanks for watching um it's kind of
nice to show Maisie as well sometimes
because everyone's used to see me
playing Aria it's nice to just you know
show you what I'm like and yeah I'm not
quite as grumpy as REM quite you know
light-hearted but yeah thanks for
watching the show and it wouldn't be
quite the way is without you guys so
yeah thanks for that amazing it's been
an absolute pleasure to meet you we've
enjoyed meeting Maisie Williams behind
the ice dog thank you thank you very
much
you